when you think of snacks at a ballgame
you think hotdogs Cracker Jacks peanuts
pretzels and of course grasshoppers okay
maybe you don't but the Seattle Mariners
and their fans sure do so how did this
crunchy critter get a spot next to your
everyday concession snacks at Safeco
Field it all starts at this restaurant
with this guy my name is Manny Arzo I'm
the Executive Chef here Pepito's the
grass lumpers our grasshoppers you know
they're a delicacy but they're also a
snack I put him on the menu here as a
novelty when we opened and we kind of
just spin on the menu for almost six and
a half years I'd describe him crunchy
like a sunflower seed salty a little bit
spicy every once in a while you get one
that's a little squishier than he'd like
we just toast them and then we put salt
meat some lime and some chili on them
and that's about all we do too long it's
one thing to see restaurant success but
Manny's grasshoppers became the
highlight of going to Mariners games
when the Mariners cuisine if we'd be a
fit for them I sent some out the
response was unreal as in 300,000 plus
grasshoppers sold they were selling out
you know before they even the first
inning and started off with 50 pounds
thinking like oh this will last us you
know a month or two it lasted us one day
to date we've probably gone through
about a thousand pounds people want more
than you know hot dogs and popcorn and
nobody else have been doing it at the
stadium so it's kind of one of these
things that I think people just really
latched on to and the popularity are
exceeded my expectations
[Music]
you
you